hello everyone and welcome to this video
on Google Palm 2 by simply learn Google
AI 21 anthropic Baidu Nvidia deepmind
meta and many other top Tech
organizations have been recently able to
build their own large language models if
you are unfamiliar with what large
language models are you can imagine you
have a huge Library full of books these
books are all filled with lots and lots
of words the last segment model is a
special machine that can read all of
these books and learn about all the
different words and phrases in them when
you talk to the machine it can use what
it has learned from all these books to
understand what you are saying and help
your answer to your question it's like
having a super smart AI who can help
your day-to-day task or find out
information for you now Google announced
the Palm 2 in its latest input output
2023 there are some amazing features in
this new llm and packs a bunch of
capabilities in this video we will
explore everything there is to know
about Google Palm 2 also X Legend your
career in Ai and ml with a comprehensive
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning gain expertise in machine
learning deep learning NLP comprovision
and reinforcement learning you will
receive a prestigious certificate
exclusive alumni membership and ask me
anything session by IBM with three cap
stones and 25 plus industry projects
using real data sets from Twitter Uber
and more you will gain practical
experience master classes by Caltech
faculty and IBM experts ensure top-notch
education simply learns job assist help
you get noticed by Leading companies
this program covers python supervised
and unsupervised learning NLP neural
network computer vision Gans Keras
tensorflow and many more skills so
enroll now and unlock exciting Ai and ml
opportunities the link is in the
description box below so without any
further delay let's get started so here
is the agenda for this tutorial
first we will discuss what is Palm 2 and
moving ahead we will discuss what can it
do what can Palm do and the third one is
how was it built and the fourth one is
what's next so moving forwards let's
discuss what is spam 2. so Palm 2
represent the latest iteration of La
language model developed by Google
building upon their extensive research
in machine learning and responsible AI
it surpasses the capability of previous
models including Palm
by demonstrating exponential performance
in various complex using tasks such as
code and math processing classification
question answering translation
multilingual proficiency and the last
one is natural language generation so
the advancement in the Palm 2 can be
attributed to a combination of factor
firstly it leverages compute optimal
scaling and enabling efficient
utilization of computational process
secondly it benefits from an enhanced
data set mixture and incorporating
diverse and comprehensive data sources
lastly the Improvement in model
architecture contribute its impressive
performance
so Palm 2 influence extent Beyond its
Standalone use as it serves as a
foundation for other Cutting Edge models
like mat Palm 2 SEC Palm 2 medical pump
2 and security pump 2. moreover it power
generates AI feature and tools at Google
such as Bard so after seeing what is
Spam 2 let's move ahead and see what can
it do so what Palm 2 can do so first one
is reasoning
so if you ask a question to Palm to on a
self there are four cars a green card
blue car and orange car and a yellow car
so this is a reasoning cushion Palm 2
surpasses previous llms such as palm and
its ability to break down integrate
tasks into more manageable subtasks
moreover it exhibits a greater
Proficiency in comprehending the
subtitles of human language Palm tools
exceptions performance shines
particularly in the realm of writing and
idioms where it adeptly grasp the
ambiguous and the figurative
connotations of word moving beyond their
little interpretations
the second one is coding
having undergone extensive pretend on a
vast area of data including web pages
source code and various data sets Palm 2
possesses remarkable Proficiency in
widely used programming languages such
as Python and JavaScript furthermore it
exhibits the ability to generate a
specialized code in language like
prologue 4ton and worry log this unique
combination of language understanding
and programming expertise enables Palm
to to facilitate collaborative efforts
across different programming language
assisting teams in their interviewers
and the third one is multilingual
translation so Palm 2 underwent
pre-training on Parallel multilingual
tests and a significantly broader Corpus
of diverse languages compared to its
predecessor Palm as a result Palm to
demonstrate exceptional Proficiency in
handling multilingual tasks surpassing
the capability of its predeces which is
Palm so moving forward let's see how was
it built through its unique design Palm
to outperforms its precedes sperm in
various tasks such as advanced reasoning
translation and code generation it
achieves the Improvement by integrating
three significant research advancement
in large language model effectively
combining and harnessing their potential
so the first one is
use of compute optimal scaling so Palm
to incorporates compute optimal scaling
as a fundamental approach ensuring that
the model size and the training data set
size are scared proportionally and the
second one is improved data set mixture
so the data set composition in Palm 2
has been enhanced compared to previous
LMS like Palm which predominantly relied
on English only text for pre-taining
data set and the third one is updated
model architecture and objective so Palm
to feature an updated model architecture
and adopts a broader objective by
training on various task this approach
enables Palm tool to require a
comprehensive understanding of different
phases of language contributing to its
enhanced language learning capabilities
so what's next so first one is mat Palm
so mad Palm is a large language model
designed to provide high quality answers
to medical questions
harnesses the power of Google large
language models which we have aligned to
the medical domain and evaluated using
medical exams medical research and
consumer queries and the second one is
SEC Palm
built on Vortex AI infrastructure and
leveraging thread landscape visibility
from Google cloud and median Google
Cloud security AI Branch gives Defender
more natural creative and effective ways
to keep their organization safe like
never before so that's all we had for in
this video we can call it our app now if
you have still any question or doubt let
us know in the comment section below and
our team of expert will help you at the
earlier thank you so much for being here
today we'll see you next time until then
stay safe keep learning with simply
learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and of Skilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here